después de 21 años de enseñar
matemáticas he aprendido que a los
chicos les gusta o no les gusta y ahora
creo que tengo 27 chicos en mi clase que
en algún momento del día dicen oye me
encantan las matemáticas
ah
desde el primer momento en que iniciamos
esto los chicos estaban muy
entusiasmados
quiero decir no paraban de hablar de
ello podía ver su entusiasmo querían
pasar horas y horas haciendo cálculos
matemáticos
de verdad estaban concentrados en ello
creo que tomando en cuenta la edad para
esta generación la tecnología es muy
importante en sus vidas todo está
relacionado con tecnología
y están muy entusiasmados con khan
academy dicen sí ya entendí las
divisiones y antes no podía hacer
divisiones
el primer día que tuve mi clase khan
academy no podía creer lo involucrados
que estaban y nadie quería salir de mi
clase así que tuve que pedirles que se
fueran a la siguiente clase y que ya
pararán de trabajar en matemáticas fue
cuando me di cuenta de que tenemos algo
bueno aquí
me gusta porque es diferente a nuestro
libro de matemáticas en el que todos
estamos haciendo lo mismo y si uno sabe
más es aburrido pero si el nivel es muy
alto nadie entiende nada cuando acabe me
está ayudando directamente porque cada
día cada niño tiene la oportunidad de
tener un aprendizaje individualizado en
lo que ellos están trabajando en su
nivel específico y obtienen respuesta
instantánea es algo que no se da en un
modelo tradicional de cátedra
yo veo a todos los estudiantes muy
involucrados en lo que están haciendo y
hablan de matemáticas se entusiasman con
las matemáticas tienen retos adecuados a
su nivel y los chicos que son brillantes
en matemáticas pueden presionar sé aún
más para lograr los objetivos que
quieren
los alumnos de secundaria les faltan
muchas bases definitivamente hay muchas
lagunas como los números negativos
fracciones decimales llegan a tercero y
dicen ya he escuchado esto y ya lo sé y
cada acá de miles dice en realidad no lo
sabes por qué no resolviste bien este
problema y los confronta con su exceso
de confianza y se dan cuenta que
necesitan aprenderlo y al final lo
aprenden por primera vez lo bueno de
khan academy es la respuesta instantánea
de los 36 alumnos que tengo algo que yo
no podría hacer cada alumno obtiene
respuesta instantánea en cada problema y
esos errores no echan raíces una de las
cosas que khan academy ha cambiado
radicalmente es que están aprendiendo
procesos y los están aprendiendo de
manera correcta no sólo aprender por
pasar uno de los grandes cambios que he
visto en nuestros alumnos es cómo se da
el aprendizaje ellos creían que el
profesor pasaba el conocimiento y ellos
entendían y aprendían por arte de magia
y cada cada me está cambiando eso ahora
los alumnos se dan cuenta que es su
responsabilidad de descifrarlo
tienen herramientas que los apoyan pero
es su responsabilidad de entenderlo
khan academy te permite regresar si no
entendiste y si ya lo aprendiste
entonces pasas a otro concepto
matemático
es realmente formidable verlos ahí en
khan academy haciendo lo suyo buscando
vídeos tratando de ligar con lo que
vimos en clase motivados
responsabilizados de su propio
aprendizaje